[Applaus]
Corona nachgehakt
darf der Staat zur Steigerung der
Impfquote eine direkte oder indirekte
Impfpflicht einführen dürfen wir uns
eine dritte booster-impfung geben wenn
zwei Drittel der Menschen noch überhaupt
nicht geimpft sind schwierige ethische
Fragen über die ich heute mit Christiane
woben sprechen möchte Christiane woben
ist Professorin für Ethik an der
Universität hier in Bonn herzlich
willkommen bei Corona nachgehakt vielen
Dank ja Frau woken in Deutschland sind
derzeit 68 Prozent der Menschen geimpft
das ist zu wenig für eine
herdenimmunität wäre denn eine
impfpflichtvertretbar für diejenigen für
die ein Impfstoff zugelassen ist
ich würde schon die These in Frage
stellen dass nur so wenige tatsächlich
geimpft sind im Sinne von sie haben eine
Immunität aufgebaut die dann zu etwas
beiträgt was man hier Immunität nennen
mag also jedenfalls an dem
immunitätsstatus in der Bevölkerung der
geeignet ist um schwere
etepidemiologische Entgleisungen also zu
viele Kranke zu viele Menschen in
Krankenhäusern und auf Intensivstationen
zu vermeiden denn wir sind gar nicht und
im Klaren darüber wie viele genesene es
eigentlich gibt und die die bei uns
offiziell als genesen definiert sind
sind ja viel zu wenige es gibt ja viele
die sind noch immun obwohl der pca-test
schon älter ist als sechs Monate wir
sind viele die sind genesen die haben
nie einen PCR-Test gehabt das heißt wenn
wir von vier Millionen genesenen in
Deutschland ausgehen und vermuten dass
sie Dunkelziffer sehr viel höher ist
dann haben wir ja allein acht bis zwölf
Millionen vielleicht jetzt mal einfach
geschätzt die schon immun sind weil sie
die Infektion hinter sich haben und wenn
sie die auf die von geimpften
vollständig geimpften drauf rechnen dann
sind wir schon über 80 Prozent
mittlerweile vielleicht darf ich dann
mal einhaken dem kann ich durchaus
folgen also vielleicht sind schon viel
größere Teile der Bevölkerung
immunisiert das ändert ja aber nichts
daran dass offensichtlich die
Prozentzahl derer die geimpft ist nicht
hoch genug ist um die vierte Welle und
im Moment durchschnittlich 60 tote pro
Tag zu verhindern sind das denn nicht
gründe genug um zu sagen wir machen
jetzt eine Impfpflicht das möchte ich ja
eben gerade sagen dass es die die
grundeinschätzung falsch ist
möglicherweise jedenfalls falsch ist
vielleicht reicht ja der
immunitätsstatus der Bevölkerung über
die Impfungen hinaus schon so weit aus
dass die Diskussion um eine Impfpflicht
weil sie jetzt direkt oder indirekt
hinfällig ist aber nehmen wir mal an was
ich eben tatsächlich nicht glaube dass
der immunitätsstatus in der Bevölkerung
noch so prekär ist dann wäre es meiner
Meinung nach der bessere Weg die
Menschen davon zu überzeugen dass die
Impfung ein guter Weg ist sowohl sich
als auch andere zu schützen und dafür
muss es viel Aufklärungsarbeit geben
dafür muss es aber vor allen Dingen in
der jetzigen Situation nach den vielen
Monaten den Dialog geben mit den
Gruppierungen und den Menschen an den
Orten die noch unsicher sind die
skeptisch sind man hört inzwischen von
so vielen die sich dann impfen lassen
wenn sie mit dem Team am Arbeitsplatz
zusammen gehen oder die beim Einkaufen
zum Impfen gehen die sich einfach quasi
mitziehen lassen die hatten vorher noch
keine richtige Entscheidung getroffen
die sind aber auch nicht wirklich klar
dagegen so dass man die noch erreichen
könnte vielleicht haben Sie auch falsche
Vorstellungen von dem was eine Impfung
ist und könnten aber im Dialog
aufgeschlossen sein und den Weg halte
ich für viel besser als eine Impfpflicht
wo sich die Politik dann wieder in die
Freiheiten der Menschen einmischen muss
also Klaus Plädoyer gegen die allgemeine
Impfpflicht was ist mit einer
Impfpflicht für bestimmte Berufsgruppen
Lehrer Kita Personal pflegende in
Krankenhäusern und Altenheimen da gibt
es ja eine Impfpflicht zum Beispiel bei
Masern und in Frankreich hat man das
jetzt auch in der corona-pandemie
eingeführt das ist das Einzige was man
glaube ich ernsthaft diskutieren kann
dass die Berufe oder die Menschen in den
Berufen an den Orten wo sie in
besonderer Weise mit gefährdeten
Personen zu tun haben und in der
Verantwortung stehen eine Impfpflicht
hätten jetzt ist aber die
masernimpflicht beispielsweise noch vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht zu entscheiden
also das wäre ja nun auch interessant
abzuwarten wie das
Bundesverfassungsgericht auf diese
Impfung reagiert und da handelt es sich
um eine sterile Impfung das ist bei
Corona nicht der Fall diejenigen die
geimpft sind können noch selber krank
werden wenn auch nicht so schwer und Sie
können auch noch andere infizieren ich
möchte mich wirklich ausdrücklich für
die Impfung aussprechen weil ich sie in
dem in der Abwägung von Chancen und
Risiken für eindeutig befürwortenswert
halte aber man kann trotzdem nur dann in
die Freiheit der Einzelnen eingreifen
wenn es sehr harte Gründe dafür gibt
jetzt scheut der Staat ja auch die
Impfpflicht aber er übt ein indirekten
Impfzwang aus durch 2G und durch teure
Tests die ich selber bezahlen muss wenn
ich in Restaurant will oder zu
bestimmten Veranstaltungen ist das denn
wirklich der bessere Weg auch das halte
ich für problematisch weil ich die zwei
g-regel auch kritisiere diejenigen die
sich testen lassen sind vom Risiko her
sich anzustecken und andere anzustecken
wenn sie sich an die anderen
Vorschriften auch halten nicht anders
aufgestellt deshalb werden sie sich
selber infizieren das ist ja dann auch
ihr eigenes Risiko aber wenn sie
wirklich qualitativ gut getestet sind
ist ja die Rate mit der festgestellt
wird ob diese Menschen infektiös sind
nicht ob sie infiziert sind aber ob sie
infektiös sind sehr hoch das liegt nach
Studien um die 94% aufwärts und insofern
bin ich für eine konsequente 3g-regel
und an bestimmten Orten würde ich auch
die geimpften und genesenen testen
lassen wenn es jetzt zu Lockerungen
kommt wie keine Masken mehr viele
Menschen an einem Ort ohne Abstand dann
wäre es gut vorher alle zu testen das
Testen so hat man ja gesehen hat die
dritte Welle mit gebrochen es war ein
wesentlicher Teil der mit zum Management
der dritten Welle positiv beigetragen
hat warum man jetzt das Testen erschwert
dann die Infektionen in die privaten
Räume verschiebt oder dann auch die
fortzahlungen diesem Fall einer
Quarantäne aussetzt so dass Menschen ja
eher dann dazu motiviert werden das gar
nicht anzuzeigen oder sich nicht testen
zu lassen ist mir ein Rätsel im Hinblick
auf ein gutes pandemie-management dass
er dazu dienen sollte Transparenz zu
haben also gegen 2G und dagegen dass die
Menschen das Testen selber bezahlen
müssen ja besonders heftig gestritten
wird bei uns immer wenn es um Kinder und
Jugendliche geht selbstverständlich und
da ist die Impfung ja durchaus
problematisch weil es unklar ist ob der
individuelle persönliche Nutzen eines
Kindes oder eines Jugendlichen bei der
Impfung wirklich gegeben ist wie
beurteilen Sie das
da sagen die Kinderärzte ja dass Kinder
ohne Vorerkrankungen unter 12 für die
ist ja derzeit ohnehin noch keine
Impfung gibt
also den alleraller seltensten Fällen
schwer erkranken sicher wissen wir noch
vieles nicht im Hinblick auch auf
mögliche Langzeitfolgen der Infektionen
aber die Kinderärzte sind da sehr
zurückhaltend dann sagen das ist für
diese Altersgruppe ja eigentlich gar
nicht ein so großes Problem wie in allen
anderen also in anderen Altersgruppen
insofern wäre ich da auch vorsichtig mit
Impfungen und impfpflichten der Umgebung
zu stark nach vorne zu treten weil es
hier eine andere Abwägung ist ich habe
auch drei Kinder eine 14-jährige Tochter
zum Beispiel die in dem Alter ist und
der Druck der Entscheidungsdruck der auf
den Eltern lastet ist relativ groß weil
die die Argumentation ist ja relativ
einfach und logisch wenn man die Kinder
nicht impft dann wird das Virus an den
Schulen grassieren auch wenn es nicht
schlimm ist für die Kinder aber das
Virus grassiert und das bedeutet im
Endeffekt dass bestimmte Regelungen wie
maskenpflicht und keine Klassenfahrten
und vieles mehr quasi
zum St nimmerleinstag an diesen Schulen
bleiben werden und das wollen die Eltern
und die Kinder natürlich auch nicht ja
das ist eine schwierige Abwägung weil
Virologen ja auch sagen irgendwann
werden wir alle mal mit diesem Virus
konfrontiert werden aber dann auf eine
Art und Weise dass die Erkrankung nicht
so schwerwiegend ist und nicht in der
Intensivstation oder mit langwierigen
Folgen endet longkow wird es glaube ich
etwas was man noch sehr genau im Auge
behalten muss
aber jetzt zu sagen wir
legen alle Maßnahmen auf eine solche
Länge fest dass wir versuchen möglichst
viele Kinder vor einer Infektion zu
schützen und ihnen also nicht zuzumuten
überhaupt diese Infektion durchzumachen
ist glaube ich etwas was man auf lange
Sicht so nicht wird durchhalten können
weder für Kinder noch für geimpfte
Jugendliche und Erwachsene die ist
wahrscheinlich auf die lange Sicht
irgendwann alle oder jedenfalls die
meisten mal treffen wird in keinem
Bereich wird die maskenpflicht so
rigoros durchgesetzt wie an den Schulen
zum Beispiel müssten Kinder
Sportunterricht in der Halle mit Maske
machen während ich zum Beispiel in
meinem Fitnessstudio ohne Maske
trainieren darf wie kann sowas sein ja
die ersten Bundesländer geben ja diese
maskenpflicht jetzt nun auch schon frei
und hören damit auf machen erste
vorsichtige Versuche das tatsächlich zu
beenden und wir müssen das ab ob das
tatsächlich vertretbar ist haben wir in
dieser Pandemie um die alten zu schützen
die Rechte der Kinder und Jugendlichen
ignoriert denn wir haben sie nicht
ignoriert wir haben dann nur nachher die
Kinder und Jugendlichen vernachlässigt
mit den Maßnahmen die man hätte
ergreifen können um sie wieder in ein
freieres Leben zurückzuführen der Umgang
mit den Schulen mit den Universitäten
mit Bildungseinrichtungen etc da ist
sich sehr viel Mühe gegeben worden auch
gerade die Digitalisierung der
Universitäten hat ja zu einem großen
Teil sehr gut geklappt anders sah das
nach meinem Kenntnis stand an den
Schulen aus die zum Teil jetzt noch
keine konsequenten digitalen Konzepte
haben für einen distanzunterricht also
da hat man meines Erachtens auch bei der
Einführung von teststrategien etc nicht
genug getan was meine ich auch noch
wichtig wäre jetzt für die weitere
Pandemie für das waren die Management
wäre es den immunitätsstatus in der
Bevölkerung wirklich mal repräsentativ
festzustellen denn es werden jetzt
ebenso viele Appelle Richtung Impfungen
und Schutzmaßnahmen
gegeben die möglicherweise also und dann
gibt es auf der anderen Seite das
polarisiert ja auch die so rufe danach
alle Maßnahmen aufzugeben so wie das in
Dänemark der Fall ist das heißt wir
müssen erstmal wissen wie ist der
immunitätsstatus in der Bevölkerung
tatsächlich das würde ich mir wünschen
auf Dänemark kommen wir gleich noch
zunächst mal eine Frage zur dritten
Impfung hatte ich ja angekündigt also
die dritte Impfung scheint einen Sinn zu
machen aber ist das auch ethisch
vertretbar wenn ich ja das gesagt zwei
Drittel der Menschen noch nicht geimpft
sind in Afrika sogar nur vier Prozent ja
es gibt eben Länder gerade im globalen
Süden da sind zum Teil nur zwei Prozent
der Bevölkerung geimpft eine
boosterimpfung sollte sehr gezielt
erfolgen und nochmal angesichts des
unklaren immunitätsstatus in der
Bevölkerung würde ich die
booster-impfung für diejenigen
reservieren zu den besonders gefährdeten
Gruppen gehören und bei denen die
Immunität nicht mehr ausreicht ansonsten
müssen wir wirklich unseren Blick auf
die weltweite Situation auch richten
denn das hat ja Rückwirkungen auch auf
uns nicht nur in der Gesundheit auch in
der Wirtschaft in den Lieferketten in
den Kulturen es hat nachher
geopolitische
geostrategische Auswirkungen und da
sollten wir eine hohe Aufmerksamkeit für
die Versorgung der Weltbevölkerung legen
Stichwort Dänemark da gibt es überhaupt
keine corona-beschränkungen mehr wie
lange können wir denn in Deutschland
noch ethisch vertretbar
corona-beschränkungen aufrechterhalten
wodurch jeder der es will sich auch
impfen lassen konnte ich würde das jetzt
nicht an der Bereitschaft der Menschen
zur Impfung festmachen sondern man kann
muss dann die corona-beschränkungen
aufheben wenn sie nicht mehr zwingend
erforderlich sind um die Situation zu
vermeiden die wir alle vor Augen haben
dass die Intensivstationen über erfüllt
sind und allzu viele Menschen daran
schwer erkranken dann muss man die
corona-beschränkungen aufheben aber eben
dosiert und vorsichtig wissen dass jetzt
Herbst und Winter kommen
im Schnitt 60 Menschen pro Tag ist das
noch genügend Rechtfertigung für all die
corona-maßnahmen oder sind wir
inzwischen an dem Punkt wo man sagen
muss das rechtfertigt keine
Freiheitsbeschränkungen mehr im Moment
sind wir wohl in einer Situation wo
vorsichtige oder geringe
Freiheitsbeschränkungen und
Vorsichtsmaßnahmen die Tests etc
durchaus noch gerechtfertigt sind das
sind ja auch Abwägungen die kann man
nicht an Zahlen eins zu eins irgendwie
festmachen andererseits aber finde ich
ist man in der Pflicht jetzt in
immunitätsstatus festzustellen damit man
eben sagen kann ja die Bevölkerung ist
jetzt so aufgestellt dass wir die
Maßnahmen beenden können und das ist ja
auch eine Frage des Vertrauens der
Bevölkerung in die Politik dass sie
alles dafür tut um die Wahrheit das
Wissen darüber herzustellen wie man eine
wirklich auch datengestützte Politik in
der Epidemiologie entscheidet in
Dänemark hat man alle Beschränkungen
aufgehoben das werden wir jetzt genau
beobachten im Moment ist in Dänemark
trotz dieser Aufhebung die Inzidenz
niedriger als in Deutschland wenn das so
bleibt wäre das ein starkes Argument aus
ihrer Sicht dafür zu sagen dann müssen
wir das in Deutschland auch aufheben ja
das ist auf jeden Fall eine Orientierung
die man aus Dänemark gewinnen kann aber
was die Forschung auch zeigt ist dass
die Dänen eben von Anfang an sehr selber
mit in die Verantwortung gegangen sind
dass sie ein hohes Vertrauen in die
Regierung haben das Opposition und
Regierung in den allermeisten Fällen an
einem Strang gezogen haben und es da
eine sehr klare
Vertrauensbasis der Bevölkerung in eine
sehr klare Politik gab und da haben wir
glaube ich in Deutschland durch die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenzen etwa eine
dieser Situation hier haben doch viele
Menschen immer mal wieder das Gefühl
gehabt da ist etwas unlogisch da etwas
ist kontrovers warum wird das in dem
einen Land so in dem anderen so gemacht
das heißt es
übermittelte dann den Eindruck als ob es
da nicht eine einheitliche Stimme gibt
und insofern ist die Vertrauensbasis und
auch die Verantwortlichkeit der Menschen
in Deutschland mit der Situation in
Dänemark glaube ich nicht ganz
vergleichbar das war Corona nachgehakt
heute mit Frau Professorin Christiane
wuppen herzlichen Dank und liebe
Zuschauer liebe Zuschauer bleiben Sie
gesund
zurück in Afghanistan das Land das ich
so viele Jahre lang immer wieder besucht
habe so